i
[Música]
hola bienvenidos aquí a américa el
espacio de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias e historias de
nuestro continente soy natalia cabrera y
esto es lo que veremos años
esta semana nos enfocamos en eeuu porque
se cumplió un año de la elección de joe
biden como presidente un proceso
electoral sin precedentes en el que se
registró la mayor participación en unos
comicios presidenciales en el país desde
1900 lo que daba cuenta de la
polarización por temas como la pandemia
el descontento con el racismo
estructural y el abuso policial entre
otros
recordemos cómo fue este caótico proceso
en el informe de rodrigo sedano
great solo esto va a hacer el mayor
desastre electoral de la historia y por
cierto se les gusta hablar de rusia y
china serán capaces de falsificar
papeletas las falsificaran harán lo que
tengan que hacer desde antes del 5 de
noviembre de 2020 el entonces presidente
de donald trump pretendía deslegitimar
el proceso electoral sin aportar pruebas
más de 60 millones de estadounidenses
votaron por correo debido a las
restricciones por la pandemia incluido
trump
un año después nadie ha demostrado
evidencias de fraude tras la votación la
cantidad de voto por correo y el
estrecho margen de votos en algunos
estados como pensilvania michigan y
wisconsin provocaron una demora en la
entrega de resultados definitivos
trump lanzó entonces una amenaza
iremos a la corte suprema de los estados
unidos queremos que se detengan todas
las votaciones
no queremos que encuentren papeletas a
las 4 de la mañana y las añadan a la
lista el entonces presidente seguía sin
aportar pruebas de sus acusaciones y su
actitud comenzó a crear división dentro
del partido republicano hasta entonces
volcado con él
un presidente en funciones que socava
nuestro proceso político y cuestiona la
legalidad de las voces de innumerables
estadounidenses sin evidencia no sólo es
peligroso y equivocado sino que socava
los propios cimientos sobre los que se
construyó esta nación finalmente tras
cuatro días de tensión el 7 de noviembre
se declaró oficialmente a joe biden como
ganador de las elecciones con los 20
votos electorales de pensilvania baiden
superaba los 270 necesarios para
declararse ganador trump no reconoció
los resultados y miles de sus
simpatizantes comenzaron a alzar la voz
en contra del supuesto fraude electoral
repitan las elecciones esta fue
completamente corrupta injusta y
tendenciosa se tomaron el poder
la tensión aumentó exponencialmente en
el país y fue posible ver a
simpatizantes del magnate ataviados en
las calles con rifles de asalto el ex
presidente y su equipo intentaron
entonces dar la vuelta a los resultados
por la vía legal el 11 de diciembre sin
embargo la corte suprema rechazó una
demanda presentada por el fiscal general
de texas que en paxton con apoyo de
trump fue un golpe casi definitivo a sus
aspiraciones que acabaron
definitivamente el 6 de enero cuando el
congreso debía certificar los resultados
de los comicios una formalidad que este
año terminó haciendo historia
nunca nos rendiremos nunca cederemos eso
no ocurre no sucede cuando hay un robo
de por medio sus palabras han sido
entendidas como un signo de aliento a
que sus seguidores asaltaran el mayor
símbolo de la soberanía nacional uno de
los mayores ataques a la democracia en
los más de 200 años de existencia de
eeuu las imágenes del asalto al
capitolio quedan para la historia el
mundo vio atónito el ataque a la
democracia estadounidense por parte de
seguidores de donald trump para el otoño
del hemisferio norte más de 600 personas
fueron arrestadas y alrededor de 100 se
declararon culpables mientras que la
defensa del ex presidente ha presentado
una serie de recursos legales para
impedir que decenas de documentos
lleguen al comité de la cámara baja que
investiga el hecho y busca determinar
quién lo organizó mientras que el ex
asesor presidencial de trump steve band
fue declarado en desacato por no
presentarse a declarar ante los
legisladores
y que ha sido del ex presidente de
estadounidense en octubre de donald
trump lanzó su propia empresa mediática
y anunció planes de abrir una red social
según un comunicado del ex mandatario
transmedia technology group busca
combatir al silicon valley trump acusa a
estas empresas de silenciar voces
opositoras en eeuu recordemos que
twitter suspendió permanentemente la
cuenta de trump el 8 de enero de este
año dos días después de la toma el
capitolio la red argumentó que había
riesgo de incitación a la violencia
pero vamos ahora a enfocarnos en la
gestión de joe biden que llegó a la casa
blanca con una larga lista de pendientes
pero la más apremiante era quizás
combatir la pandemia del cob y 19 el 14
de diciembre de 2020 se aplicó la
primera vacuna en eeuu con el programa
en marcha para cuando alguien llegó a
washington el nuevo mandatario iba a
cosechar su consecuente disminución de
nuevos contagios y el renacimiento de la
economía pero se encontró con el
obstáculo de los escépticos para cumplir
sus metas
yo bailé prometió aplicar 100 millones
de dosis de la vacuna contra el joven 19
en sus primeros 100 días en el cargo es
decir para el 30 de abril el 62 se
produjo el día 58 de su mandato el 10 de
marzo para cuando se acercaba la fecha
estipulada el 28 de abril ya 200
millones de personas habían sido
inmunizadas jean-max vacunarnos es lo
mejor que podemos hacer para luchar
contra estas variantes
si bien millones de personas están
vacunadas necesitamos que millones más
se vacunen de bailén se fijó entonces
una nueva meta alcanzar la inmunidad de
rebaño es decir que el 70 por ciento de
los 330 millones de habitantes del país
estuvieran protegidos a las
celebraciones del día de independencia
el 4 de julio para lograrlo se habilitó
la vacunación de mayores de 16 años
primero y luego de 12 pero al llegar el
mes de junio las cifras de vacunación
que tuvieron uno de los mejores inicios
del mundo mostraron un claro
estancamiento
alrededor de 90 millones de
estadounidenses elegibles para vacunarse
y que optaron por no hacerlo según el
'new york times' se dividen en dos
quienes rechazan vehementemente las
vacunas contra el coronavirus un grupo
compuesto por blancos que viven en el
campo cristianos evangélicos y
políticamente conservadores y los
abiertos a vacunarse pero están
esperando para tomar una decisión al
respecto un grupo diverso compuesto por
habitantes de las ciudades jóvenes
negros y latinos y demócratas con la
variante delta circulando por el país
los estados y condados con bajas tasas
de inmunización se empezaron a ver
afectados por el aumento de contagios
todavía tenemos mucha gente sin vacunar
a
la pandemia que tenemos ahora es una
pandemia de los no vacunados entonces
por favor por favor por favor si no está
vacunado protéjase y proteja a los niños
es importante
wii más de 104.000 personas murieron de
kobe 19 entre junio y septiembre de 2021
según la universidad johns hopkins la
abrumadora mayoría no estaban vacunados
según la kaiser family foundation
concluyó que las vacunas podrían haber
evitado más de 90.000 muertes expertos
atribuyen el escepticismo a la
desinformación la falta de credibilidad
en el gobierno y la politización de la
pandemia para combatirlo vall d'en
anunció beneficios económicos para
quienes se vacunarán mientras que los
centros para el control y prevención de
enfermedades ya aprobaron dosis de
refuerzo de las tres vacunas disponibles
en la unión americana que sigue siendo
la más golpeada por la pandemia
y otra coyuntura de 2020 que ayudó a que
va a ir en llegar a la casa blanca fue
el hartazgo con la violencia policial y
el racismo estructural la muerte del
afroamericano georg floyd en mayo a
manos de un policía blanco motivó una
revisión profunda de las prácticas
policiales y de la sociedad en sí misma
miles de estadounidenses salieron a las
calles del país a gritar que las vidas
negras importan bailén prometió a unir
al dividido país y una reforma policial
que ya quedó sepultada en el congreso
[Música]
mayrén recibió un eeuu polarizado y dijo
que era tiempo de sanar con esto en la
mira los demócratas presentaron el
proyecto de ley justicia por georg que
fue aprobado en la cámara de
representantes pero se estancó en el
senado
con patriotas tenemos que unirnos para
reconstruir la confianza entre las
fuerzas del orden y las personas a las
que sirven para erradicar el racismo
sistémico en nuestro sistema judicial y
penal y para promulgar la reforma
policial el nombre de georg floyd que ya
aprobó la cámara sé que los republicanos
tienen sus propias ideas y participan en
discusiones productivas con los
demócratas en el senado
la manzana de la discordia era la
inmunidad calificada una medida que
protege a los oficiales y funcionarios
públicos de ser procesados en juicios
civiles el proyecto de ley proponía
además prohibir maniobras de ahogamiento
limitar las transferencias de equipo
militar a la policía crear un registro
nacional de agentes despedidos por
abusos entre otros
si bien no fue posible hacer nada a
nivel federal a nivel estatal los
gobernadores tomaron algunas medidas
para combatir el abuso policial
no
precisamente la organización human
rightswatch propone que los fondos para
la policía se reorienten a financiar
servicios sociales escuelas sistemas de
atención de la salud basados en la
comunidad para limitar los perjuicios
causados por esa fuerza y mejorar la
seguridad pública
además el estallido llevó a algunos
cambios reales como el retiro de
monumentos a líderes confederados
pasando por el mundo del entretenimiento
y el deporte donde por ejemplo el equipo
de fútbol americano redskins de
washington cambió de nombre y de lobo en
medio de la presión de los
patrocinadores mientras que en el mundo
empresarial la compañía quaker retiró el
logo de los productos aunque maiman tras
más de 130 años en el mercado al
reconocer que está basado en
estereotipos raciales
además va a ir en reconoció como feriado
nacional el 19 de junio el ginseng
también conocido como el día de la
independencia negra un feriado federal
para conmemorar la emancipación de los
afroamericanos esclavizados
y el voto de los latinos también fue muy
importante para bailén en arizona un
estado tradicionalmente republicano se
les atribuye su victoria y en texas que
en esa ocasión rompió récords de
participación por los nuevos votantes
latinos trump perdió la ventaja que
había conseguido en 2016 nuestro
corresponsal en washington cristóbal
vázquez nos hace un balance de la
relación con nuestra comunidad
365 días después de su elección
aunque bailen ganó el voto latino en el
2020 con un 59% versus un 38% de trump
el actual presidente perdió 17 puntos de
apoyo en la comunidad latina con
respecto a hillary clinton en el 2016
así lo reporta el centro de
investigación motivo para que grupos
demócratas como building back to get
there hayan empezado desde hace meses ya
hacer campaña a favor de joe biden y del
partido demócrata de cara a las
elecciones al congreso del próximo año y
es que para los demócratas el voto
latino es muy importante si quieren
mantener la mayoría en el congreso algo
que muchos analistas consideran poco
probable la relación en todo caso entre
latinos y bailén sigue bajo tensión
porque a pesar de que en sus primeros
meses firmó órdenes ejecutivas tratando
de desmontar medidas de trump contra la
comunidad los jóvenes soñadores en su
mayoría latinos todavía no tienen un
camino a la ciudadanía o la legalidad
permanente en este país como lo prometió
bailen en campaña en términos
migratorios su administración
y mantenido en pie el título 42 una
medida implementada por donald trump que
bajo pretexto de salud pública por la
pandemia permite expulsar a cualquier
persona que trate de entrar a eeuu de
forma ilegal o espere su decisión de
asilo en este país así que aunque las
intenciones hayan sido positivas sus
promesas no se han cumplido y esto le
puede pasar factura en las próximas
elecciones
y una de las banderas de la campaña de
bailén fue el regreso de eeuu al
multilateralismo luego de cuatro años de
la administración trump en las que
retiró a eeuu del acuerdo nuclear con
irán del pacto de parís contra el cambio
climático y empezó una guerra comercial
con china sin embargo valve no ha
escapado de las tensiones diplomáticas
como la generada por la firma de un
tratado con australia y reino unido-
para el desarrollo de submarinos de
propulsión nuclear que canceló un
millonario contrato con francia
generando fricciones
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
especial de aquí américas hoy natalia
cabrera pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas sigan con más en france 24 y
france24 puntocom
[Música]